[Musique]
ob écouter les l'heure de manger deux
heures qu'on est là il ya deux ans à
melbourne appétit quand tout le monde
vous voyez c'est pour moi ça là j'en
aurais pas fait assez et souvent ça vous
a pas mis en appétit ce matin va oui ça
vous met en appétit avant moi moi ça me
dépeignent ça me décourage moi aussi
mais regardez maintenant ça y est je
commence à avoir un peu plus chaud et
qu'est ce que vous faites je vais faire
des sandwiches au regard des 1 depuis
aujourd'hui
ah bon voyez-vous le sandwich c'est par
définition l'art d'accommoder les restes
alors nous avons des restes des restes
de poulet des restes de pif tech et vous
croyez que les mamans confieront ça aux
enfants pour miel 1 b ccc il faut il
faut il faut il faut que j'en ai besoin
les lunettes vous jeter ses camps dans
les bateaux et quand dans la foulée
manger on jette intérieur manger pour
l'instant rien mais on va manger alors
là comme ça alors ici je vais commencer
pas émincer la salade
je vous ai vu plein de la salade
commandés paient leur solde
je suis pas nourri sans manger un
appétit d'ogre je vais faire la cuisine
je vais pas parler des choses oui ou la
salade ça s'appelle de la chiffonnade ça
finira c'est joli il ya de jolies
nombreuses images a pris la frisée pour
faire ça au nom ça se fait pas je ne
savais pas alors de la laitue cette la
lecture c'est la lecture alors d'aller
tuer un jeune ami ne l'avait plus
[Musique]
au grand vent du large est salée aux
apps tabs taoub que c'est joli c'est la
mayonnaise
non le préparer même pas au nom alors je
vais mélanger la mayonnaise avec être
que je tienne quand vous êtes gentil
toujours à kusel affectueuse avec moi
puissions des récipients plastiques la
whey tout cas c'est beaucoup
le pas de récipients plastiques non
voilà à la mayonnaise l'habitude à la
mayonnaise avec de la laitue et puis et
puis je m'en avez vous reste et puis je
me repens une tomate
lindsay lohan est de vous et moi ça l'a
écouté des petits camarades qui sont là
ils prépareront leurs sandwichs eux
mêmes selon leur goût ils auront un
personnel parce que ça ça aussi c'est
encore d'un coût de tous il faut penser
que chacun doit préparer les sandwichs
comme il aime pas il fait froid
moi je me contenterai de claquer des
dents fait ce livre des données dans ce
qu'on apprend que j'avais déjà là dedans
et en plus si je la claque ça va être du
plan mental et je continuais ça que je
suis content cooper 9 à 9 durent laisser
cuire là bas mais puisqu'il est votre
réchauffe mais il sous la menace a bola
il est à sa place
encore un avenir de la mayonnaise
oui en fait si je sais ça mais moi je
manque d'imagination parce que le
sandwich que je suis en train de
préparer ils en ont ils en ont dans la
dans la cuisine il s'appelle le club
sandwich à quelque chose près ça c'est
du gruyère
ça c'est pour alors ça sert à ça laisse
une histoire qu'est ce qu'est ce qui est
vert qui est dans une cage qui sifflent
et c est tout ça c'est nous
non c'est un hareng saur mais en
l'occurrence saïdi pourquoi il n'est pas
vers l'avant soirée d'innocence et pour
compliquer un tout petit peu l'histoire
évidemment c'est là aussi pour
compliquer un peu l'histoire je mets du
fromage de gruyère d'un sandwich
effectivement le fromage de gruyère
mélanger à la salade c'est très très bon
autres mon attention c'est du coeur
d'hérault ces données avant paris alors
je vais ajouter de la mayonnaise
voilà les parents enseigne l'économie
aux enfants si vous leur faites des
trucs comme ça ça va et se nourrissant
qui ne se nourrissent que c'est ce qu'il
faut voir ce qu'il faut voir c'est le
résultat pour commencer mais ça devient
lourd est là alors maintenant je vais
commencer à préparer le sanwi
alors il est où je vais prendre comme
ceux ci de la salade avec de la
mayonnaise je vais l'installer sur le
banc si je suis en tout cas j'ai pas
encore si c'est donc s'il reste quelque
chose avec le vent ben non concurrents
s'ils restent eux rien puisque voulant
se faire une raison la france que vous
avez misé sur la note petites nappes
improvisé la voit la balle et ça s'est
joué alors maintenant nous la notion de
fantaisie pas intervenir
alors là vous pouvez avoir une aile de
poulet que vous avez gardé
consciencieusement gamme on peut tirer
plaisir à votre petit réfrigérateur
portatif alors vous pouvez en coupe et
conseils neutres âge ou deux puis vous
mettiez une tranche comme ça une tranche
comme c'est par exemple
alors ici et vous vous mettez également
une proche
et puis une autre si gentil de nous
donner ces idées là parce que c'est vrai
plan suisse vous mettez le jeu par
exemple ici un ordre respect alors non
seulement pour faire la nique aux noms
l'ordre il faut le garder dans la terre
à l'intérieur de la toile de tente mais
pas dans le sandwich
non alors ensuite vous avez du bacon
taillon cousin est fait griller on est
resté un tout petit peu
bah vous mettez une de toi je rigole ça
fait rire et si vous n'en avez pas et
bien vous allez en acheter un nonos sais
pas ce que je voulais dire non si vous
n'avez pas vidé avant pour vous en
passer là alors on peut aussi avoir des
restes de bifteck comme ceci alors si
vous avez des petits obus tirés
les couper en tranches très fines et
puis alors vous allez voir j'ai fait
quelque chose qui va peut-être paraître
ridicule que tout à fait penser à une
fois n'est pas lola j'enlève le lard
n'est ce pas puisque supposons que l'on
n'en ayons pas c'était la proposition
vous veniez de alors vous mettez à la
place les laitages de steak mais soit
sur les séries mais en dessous du poulet
du coup lui il voulait un étrange de
bifteck
voilà non mais vous êtes sûr que vous
êtes en train de faire dans je suis sûr
je suis sûr que cette excellence alors
je n'ai alors royaume et et l'étrange
qui comme celles de tomates
oui voilà un c'est encore des sandwichs
ce qu'on peut pas tenir dans la main ce
n'est pas question de les tenir dans la
main il est question de les tenir dans
la bouche n'est pas les ennuis c'est
fait pour être mangés alors là voyez
vous toutes les combinaisons sont encore
possibles c'est à dire
vous pouvez ajouter du jambon du jambon
blanc du jambon de paris que l'on trouve
très très facilement un peu partout
comme ceci n'est pas un pari pas
tellement non pas tellement pris et puis
vous allez ajouter bien entendu la
salade à ça c'est pour faire des
économies là qu'est l'os à l'adresse pas
est justement destinée
assaisonnez le tout carrière la
mayonnaise la mayonnaise et dans la
salade et dietmar aimant avec sandwichs
là oui ça s'appelle un club aurillacois
ya le rdda la viande le plat complet à
salade
ouais elle dessert huile et la ballade
des soeurs on ira le cueillir là nous
avons derrière nous des framboisiers ce
site mais nous irons nous jeter sur les
framboises vous souvenez quand nous
étions enfants il y avait avec un an
morceaux choisis qui racontait que monde
il y avait la grand-mère en compte et
les framboises vous rappeler sa non non
ne pas l'être le communal vous dit tout
moi oui c'est à l'école communale comme
si tu allais un tout petit peu avant moi
louis et 25 hommes alors voilà voilà
oh la la maman c'est le vent bon alors
voyez vous nous avons ici trouver une
combinaison de sandwiches mais des
combinaisons en sandwich nous en aurons
autant que nous voudrons en ce sens
que tout compte fait n'est-ce pas il
s'agit de l'utilisation des restes et
bien catherine je vous donnais un de ses
sandwichs vous allez essayer de manger
et puis je pense que il s'agit de
l'utilisation des restructurations et
reste dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
c'est à dire que c'est extrêmement
d'appétissants c'est joli c'est et ça
n'a fait pas du tout l'utilisation des
restes ne va pas du tout alors la
mayonnaise avec la salade c'est
rafraîchissant l'oeuf dur là thomas le
morceau de bifteck viennent de là ça va
faire ça je suis alors qu'est ce qu'on
leur dit
[Musique]